[Music]
Hilary Swank embracing mom life I mean
come on the actress revealed she
welcomed twins with husband Phillip
Schneider sharing the happy news on
Instagram over Easter weekend I would
say day in and day out I'm very blessed
well it wasn't easy but boy and girl was
it worth it happy Easter posting from
Pure Heaven it's been magical Hillary
didn't offer any details about her
little ones opting to keep the kiddos
names private too
I'm gonna be a mom
the new mom announced her pregnancy back
in October this is um something that
I've been wanting for a long time and
not just a one but of two oh really yeah
believe it
two of those babies in there yes I do
and the star shared that expecting twins
wasn't exactly surprising what his twins
meme that's twins means too yeah my
grandmother was a twin my husband's
grandmother was a twin oh my God so we
have twins in our in our linear in your
DNA yes isn't it crazy I know it's just
so crazy earlier this year Hillary
opened up to E.T about experiencing her
first pregnancy in her 40s Hillary how
has this experience been for you it's
been so wonderful I love being pregnant
and it's just nice to see a lot of women
in their 40s going you gave me hope I'm
hope I'm something that can happen you
like have a different thought pattern
you know what I mean you get out of your
own way of course she proudly documented
her bump Journey along the way and now
that baby girl and boy are here we're
sure to get lots more moments like these
with Hillary I just feel so blessed and
so happy happier than I've ever felt
foreign